un point sur la situation en guadeloupe
où depuis une semaine la tension ne
retombe pas partie d'une mobilisation
contre le pass sanitaires et
l'obligation vaccinale des soignants la
crise s'est transformé en une vague de
protestations bien plus large les
précisions sur place de livan sepric a
et l'hindi déclare
pas d'évolution de la situation ici en
guadeloupe non à l'obligation vaccinale
non à la hausse des prix c'est le même
son de cloche cole en plus on est en
dessous toutes les lèves ici entre
colère et détermination les
guadeloupéens ne compte pas relâcher la
pression et compte bien se faire
entendre ils se disent bien souvent
délaissée par les instances
gouvernementales
le début
nous n'avons pas vu nos élus avec nous
nous n'avons pas entendu et jusqu'à
présent c'est pareil tant que nous
n'aurons pas des élus en responsabilité
nous aurons toujours cette difficulté là
vous pouvez parler tant que vous voulez
à la rectrice vous pouvez parler tant
que vous voulez auprès fait vous pouvez
parler tant que vous voulez au directeur
de l'hôpital même si celui ci est un
guadeloupéen il n'est là que pour
exécuter est donc temps que nous serons
dans cette situation déplorable nous ne
pouvons pas faire avancer la guadeloupe
on a fait des défilés chaque samedi des
meetings chaque jeudi pendant quatre
mois sans compter sentinelle guadeloupe
qui sous le réseau depuis
encore plus longtemps fait des alertes
de diversion interpellant les politiques
locaux jamais personne n'a daigné nous
adosser parole c'était une autre était
de complotiste m'ont traité de
révolutionnaire ou non traitées
d'indépendantistes or il ne s'agit de
rien de tout cela rend dépendants bat
pour l'indépendance on est en train de
se battre ou d atteinte fondamentale aux
libertés fondamentales justement pour
l'instant aucune fin de conflit à
l'horizon la contestation déterminée et
la défiance vis-à-vis de l'état
s'ajoutent au passé tumultueux de lille
mouvement de protestation est bel et
bien installé sous la wallonie